welcome back everyone okay so in the
last few lectures we've been building up
these balancing transformations these
coordinate transformations from my
original state vector X to some new
coordinate system Z where my
controllability and observability
grampians become equal and balanced this
was a great idea by Moore in 1981 and
one of the nice things about this is
that there are error bounds so for a
given model order we know kind of we
know how good or how bad the model is
how much information were thrown away
so something important to think about
remember we had our original system
let's call it X dot equals ax plus B u
and y equals CX and what we were going
to do is find this balancing
transformation in terms of some new
let's call them tilde coordinates X
tilde dot equals a tilde X tilde plus B
tilde you remember this is what we get
when we go through our balancing
transformation and then truncate and
keep only the first our most
controllable and observable modes where
R is a lot less than the dimension of X
ok so the there's essentially a way of
quantifying how good this reduced order
model approximates the input-output
characteristics of this full order model
so let's remember this is called the
full order model sometimes people call
it the fom I like full order model this
is the ROM the reduced order model high
dimensional low dimensional so this is
dimension n this is dimension R ok where
R is much much less than n very
important so there's ways of quantifying
how good the reduced order model
approximates the input-output
characteristics
okay and so remember I can always take
my state space system and I can get an
Associated transfer function G of s
where this is my complex Laplace
variable and I can do the same thing
here and I can get G tilde of s this is
my reduced approximation of that
transfer function now this is nice
because these kind of are the same size
if this is if I have like two inputs and
three outputs
then this is a 3x2 matrix of transfer
functions and this is a 3x2 matrix of
transfer functions even though my state
dimension went down my inputs and
outputs didn't change that's really
important in this reduced order modeling
framework U and Y are the same because
my system in reality is like a black box
my system it has some you in and it has
some Y out I can't change that but I can
get a different approximation of what's
that's going on in the guts of the
system the a B and C matrices okay so
essentially there's a norm called the
infinity norm I think that this is the
worst case scenario norm so the infinity
norm of G is infinity norm of G it
sounds super cool right infinity norm of
G is the max over all frequencies on the
comp you know all frequencies of the
maximum singular value of G I Omega okay
so this is a handful let me just walk
you through this so first of all if this
if this G is a scalar if I have a single
input and a single output so this is
just a scalar function then you can
forget this Sigma one there's no
singular values all I'm doing is I'm
evaluating this transfer function at all
frequencies this basically means I
inject a sinusoidal frequency at
frequency Omega T and I see how big is
the output response or how small of the
output response then what I do is I
sweep across all frequencies and I find
the biggest possible output response to
that given frequency okay that's that's
all that this is saying is I basically
want to sweep through the frequency
response of G and I want to find the
biggest possible frequency that
amplifies everything then it's amplified
by these dynamics if I happen to have
multiple inputs and multiple outputs
than this is a matrix and so I picked
the maximum singular value of that
matrix okay that's what this infinity
norm is and what we want for control
okay so essentially the goal of control
and this is another way of saying what I
was saying earlier the goal here is for
the norm of G minus G tilde the infinity
norm to be small
now small you know it's relative what
what is small for your system might be
different than for my system okay so but
the basic idea is after I go through
this this balance truncation procedure
or any model reduction procedure maybe
there's something better than balance
truncation it's not optimal it's just a
good strategy when I get this G tilde I
want it to be close to my original
transfer function G in this
infinity-norm
okay that's what we want this is what
you compute and so the nice thing about
this is that there are upper and lower
bounds based on balance truncation so
upper bound lower bounds let's just
write these down upper and lower bound
okay
and when I say the Infinity norm of the
difference what I mean when I call this
the worst case scenario what I mean is
is there some particular magic input you
some special u I can force the system at
just the right frequency where this G
hat my approximation looks really really
different than my original transfer
function G that's why it's the worst
case scenario because if there's even
one frequency where these are really
different then this infinity norm is
gonna be big so I basically am
tightening down the agreement between G
and my approximation G tilde over all
frequencies and any of those frequencies
start to get bad approximations I call
my model bad okay that's why this is
such a really like tough norm the
infinity norm is the worst case scenario
norm okay so we have an upper bound on
what G minus G tilde is so the Infinity
norm and we have a lower bound on G
minus G tilde infinity norm and these
are based in terms of the singular
values of my Graham Ian's okay so let me
I should probably write this down for
you right remember what we had was in my
new coordinates WC hat equals wo hat
equals Sigma this diagonal matrix okay
controllability Graham Ian and
observability
in my new transform coordinates are our
diagonal and these diagonal elements are
called the Hankel singular values very
important Henkel Hinkle's a person
henkle singular values and so the diet
the elements of Sigma are essentially
little Sigma one little Sigma two da
little Sigma let's call this you know
there's a lot of these there'll be okay
in the original system X is n by n
that's my high dimensional system we
transform this into balanced coordinates
Z this is still N by N and that's the
that's what I'm talking about here this
is an N by n Graeme and this is an N by
n Graeme and this is an N by n diagonal
matrix so I have n singular values and
recall what we do to get tilde is we
basically just chop this off at the
first R we take the first R of these and
we throw away everything everything else
okay so these are called the Hankel
singular values are the singular values
of my high dimensional system and these
upper and lower bounds can be written in
terms of these singular values so the
procedure is you know you have this big
system I compute its gram ian's I
compute its singular values and I can
quantify how good is a ma is a order our
model given the distribution of these
singular values okay so the upper bound
this is less than or equal to 2 times
the sum from basically the sum of all
the stuff I'm throwing away J equals R
plus 1 to n of Sigma J pretty simple
okay basically just add up all of the
singular values I'm throwing away that's
an upper bound
you know my error it can't be worse than
all this stuff away and the lower bound
this is greater this is really cooll
greater than Sigma R plus 1 so my lower
bound my error is never lower than the
next singular value that I throw away it
can't possibly be lower than that and is
never bigger than the sum of all the
singular values I throw away why do we
want to have these expressions why is
this so important this is important
because if I have a thousand or a
million dimensional system and I'm
designing the controller for it what I
might want to do is instead of saying oh
I'm just gonna use an order five model
arbitrarily I might say I want a model
that captures 99% of the input-output
energy and so I will choose R so that
I'm kind of bounded I'm guaranteed to
have you know at least 99% of that input
output energy according to these bounds
that's very useful and that depends on
what this distribution of singular
values looks like so if I plot Sigma J
versus J usually I plot log of Sigma J
because these tend to decay fast there's
two fundamental behaviors that you can
see and this is an oversimplification so
one of those behaviors is a very very
fast drop-off in the singular values
like this and this is analog scale so
these are ultra fast decay of my
singular value energy what this means is
that Sigma 1 is a lot bigger than Sigma
2 is a lot bigger than Sigma 3 and so on
which means that my first mode is a lot
more controllable and observable my
second mode is a lot more controllable
and so on and so forth so if I chop this
off there's a very clear point where I
can chop this off and capture almost all
of the energy and still have a very low
dimensional model because I'm throwing
away all of these unobservable and
uncontrollable nodes but what might also
happen in a lot of systems and really
complex systems is I might have a fast
decay and then a really slow gradual
drop-off in singular values and this is
a lot less clear where to truncate
because the sum of all of the stuff I
truncate might be pretty big there might
be a pretty big upper bound on my error
and so choosing a good are a good order
of your model for these systems can be
harder they're harder to control they
have more stuff that that you can
control in the systems so you know
what's an example of controllability and
observability kind of physically what
are some of these blue curves here so
you're driving your car you have a
steering wheel you have a gas pedal you
have brakes you have a shifter but you
have a lot of other stuff you have a
radio you have an air conditioner you
have your windows right so
all of these modes are essentially like
turning the radio up or rolling my
windows down like these are knobs I
these are states of my system but they
don't matter at all to going from point
A to point B okay so these are kind of
uncontrollable and unobservable with
respect to the real dynamics of where my
car is going I hope that makes sense
there's things that actually matter from
the control objective why and there's
things that don't so that's what these
blue things are is like you know turning
my radio up or down okay
all right really really important your
Grammy ins your balance truncation model
has upper and lower bounds in terms of
the singular values of your Grammy ins
which are called your Hankel stick euler
values very important and we'll talk
more about this later thank you